[Music]
Yeah,
wait, wait, wait, I made it. I
just went to such a baron, and I got two medals
.
Immediately Reihi Radaren Evil-sama
At this timing, the training continues in the auto layer. The
air is too
unreadable. 5 Benberi-sama Miso is No. 10 Elise.
It's a bit of a humorous concubine strategy to appeal in front of you. Part 3 of the enemies.
I thought I was there, but
ah ah ah,
I'm not umbilical, but
I lived together, so
what about Belize?
I think it's normal to have a concubine, and the liner feeling is the same with everyone.
Hmm
[Music] I'm
worried about gimmick concubine Daisakusen umbilical cord prevention
Then it's ok
[Music]
Hey Rocket Osawa It
looks like I'm having fun
[Music]